The Father, His Sons, and the Sticks.
A father had three sons who were always arguing among themselves.
Nothing he said would stop them,...
...and so one day, he decided to show them something that would make them think.
"Go into the forest," he said, "and bring me back some sticks."
The sons did as he asked and soon came back with some sticks.
He took the sticks from them and tied them together.
"Try to break these sticks in two," he said.
Each of the sons tried to break the sticks in two, but they could not.
"Now try to break the sticks one at a time." he told them.
The sons each took a stick out of the bundle and broke it easily.
"If you all work together and do not quarrel," the father said,...
..."You will be strong. If each of you go your own way, you will be weak."